بشق الانفس وقبل اربعه ايام من استحقاق
الديون تخطت صفقه بايدن كارثي عثرت مجلس
النواب فالاخير اقر التشريع باغلبيه كبيره
شملت اصوات 314 نائبا وفيما عارضه 117
نائبا بينهم واحد وسبعون جمهوريا وبعد
اقراره في مجلس النواب تنتقل الكره الان
الى مجلس الشيوخ حيث الاغلبيه الديمقراطيه
وبعد موافقه الغرفتين ينشره بايدن كقنون
نافذ رئيس الامريكي اكد عدم حصول اي من
الطرفين على كل ما يريدونه بموجب الاتفاق
مشددا على ان الطريق الوحيد المضي قدما هو
تسويه بين الحزبين رئيس مجلس النواب
الجمهوري كاظم مكارسي من جهه وصف اقرار
قانون المسؤوليه الماليه بخطوه اولى حاسمه
لاعاده بلاده الى المسار الصحيح مكارسي
اضافه ان مشروع القانون ينص على اكبر خفض
للمزريه في التاريخ الامريكي منتقدا ادمان
الانفاق في واشنطن المفاوضات الماراثونيه
اذا التي انتهت بشكل جيد وفق بايدن لم
تعجب الجمهوريين المحافظين الذين انتقدوا
عدم تامينها المزيد من التخفيضات الجاده
للانفاق كما شكك بعض اعضاء الحزب الجمهوري
في ملائمه مكارسي للقياده مع تنازلاته
الكثيره التي ادخلوها خانه الخذلان
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات